how did you
initially get involved in the whole
drone program in the first place
so um i like i said i joined to be an
intel operator
operator um and they told me that i'd be
working with people like james bond and
[ __ ]
and you know played on my my 19 year old
ego
and sense of adventure but when i
got through intel school i was in the
top 10 percentile of my class
and so they chose me
well really they cho i was the first
my class was the first class to be
shoved into this program
and then basically every class after me
for a year were shoved into the drone
program to the point where they had too
many people
in it um and so
it was more an act of
um finding bodies to put into it
than anything else and i even tried to
get out like when i went when i showed
up to the
creech air force base they told us that
our job was to kill people and break
things and i even went
to my commander and was like i i didn't
sign up to do this and he was like
are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] are you going to
do their job didn't you not swear in
order to defend the constitution against
all enemies foreign and dominic
uh foreign and domestic and i was like
yeah and he's like well then get out
there and do your [ __ ] job
you know and i was just an airman first
class i was the bottom
of the totem pole and this guy was a
lieutenant colonel
who the [ __ ] am i to talk against this
guy
right but if i was if i had if i had
listened to my heart
and if i had listened to the teachings
of my grandfather
i would have been like yeah [ __ ] you i'm
not gonna do this
uh but that's that's not necessarily the
case and
when i look at back at my um
time in the drones i i scored a 92 on my
asvab which is the military aptitude
test
most of the people that i was with
scored less than a 50.
so the minimum the minimum to be in the
drone program was a 45
on the test and so really what they
wanted was bodies
you know they were ramping up the
program they needed people to sit
in the seat to
to do the job um when i was in the 15th
reconnaissance squadron i was the first
mac qualified uh drone operator
and mac is multi-aircraft control where
basically a drone operator flies the
aircraft himself with
with the just the assistance of a pilot
and there were plenty of people that
were in my squadron that could not do
that job because they did not have the
aptitude to
monitor and take care of a plane by
themselves
and um what kind of things were on this
aptitude test like what qualities were
they testing you for
it's it's basically like reading
comprehension
mechanical comprehension linguistic
comprehension
um
there's four categories i can't remember
the fourth category um
is it true that they they they
specifically look for gamers like people
who
are are professional video game players
um
maybe now but that wasn't the case um
when
okay bye um
when uh there was a lot of us that
played video games when we were in
the uh uh military especially world of
warcraft there was a whole bunch of us
that played that together
and you can definitely tell that there
is a skill set
that is directly involved with this
program
you know the hand-eye coordination the
ability to
instantly recognize whatever button
presses that you need to do in order to
to make the action happen it's not
really that complicated
not nothing near as complicated as
playing world of warcraft
um but there was definitely a skill set
um
if you if you even just look at the
stick control it was like
if you were able to play microsoft
flight simulator with a joystick
you were able to do this and there were
a lot of people
that you know their stick control was
really horrible where they
they took this the control stick and
they would be like bloop
bloop bloop bloop like so the camera
would go down
uh uh uh like so there was no
the camera didn't have the smooth
controls on it
right right um and you could definitely
tell
the difference between someone who was
put in the program
and without any uh real skill versus
someone who practiced that school a long
time
uh over in europe uh
they are recruiting gamers for their own
programs like in norway and
england in the uk they are
going to video game conferences and i
have had video
uh feed videos given to me
and people who go to these conferences
talk to me about this type of stuff and
tell me what is going on
i've not done that myself so maybe i
probably should at some point
um if you go if you go over to
um
there are these weapons conventions
military technology conventions
that happen um and they happen a lot
over in europe
uh and that one of the guys that goes
over there
talks to these dudes um and what they're
recruiting and how they're saying
they'll talk to little kids
they'll talk to little kids and be like
oh do you play call of duty
um even in the united states like
the recruiters will show up um there's
been a couple times in my own hometown
where they'll show up with a semi truck
and they'll be have like united states
military on the back of it
they'll be and inside will be um
seats for kids to play video games like
call of duty and they'll be like if you
come talk to us for 15 minutes we'll let
you play call of duty for 30.
right so they'll use
those things to to recruit and they'll
say things like
you know do you really do you want to be
a real superman do you want to be a real
hero do you want to be
you know all those types of propaganda
nonsense that
kids would be like yeah i want to be a
hero i want to do something good i want
to fight for
glory i want this or they'll even go to
gang they'll even recruit gang members
who are like
you know who want the training who want
the experience just so that they can go
back into the game for the most part the
people that i was with
the beginning were not that intelligent
and they were just bodies put in the
seat because they just needed someone
to man the camera they hadn't developed
the technology to do it automatically
with artificial intelligence
so when you first got into the program
what was your job like what kind of what
sort of title did they give you
and what specifically were you doing
with the drones were you flying them
were you were you shooting the missiles
like
what exactly were you doing so i was a
mq1 bravo predator sensor operator
and that is just a glorified cameraman
you know i point the the camera at the
target
the pilot uh will tell me to pull the
point the laser which guides the missile
to impact and the pilot will pull the
trigger
so that the missile comes off the rail
but i'm the one that guides the missile
to
the target um about a month after i
finished training i was flying planes on
my own
i flew planes on my own for about eight
years how long
eight months and that means with bear
with minimal pilot input
you know so there's an officer pilot and
an enlisted sensor operator
and i was the enlisted dude the reason
why they have
a pilot in the other seat
is because pilots are
jtac qualified um
so they're qualified to drop ordinance
at with the
approval of a joint tactical air
controller on the ground
um who watches our video feed and
confirms that that's what they want
us to do and the jtac is the guy who
he basically knows what every single
ordinance does
in its impact radius percent of
incapacitation which is like
in order for us to fire within uh
with friendlies on the ground there must
be a point one percent of incapacitation
which for the predator missile is 105
what does that mean that means that uh
there's point one percent
of uh loss of friendly life
uh at 105 meters of impact
loss of friendly life yeah meaning u.s
troops yes so like if there were troops
in the area like a jtac on the ground
with a
convoy uh and the jtag even if we knew
that they were within range of in
incapacitation if the jtac says we are
and 106 meters away
right he is saying that we are one meter
away
from a point one percent incapacitation
even if they're like
50 meters from it sometimes the jtac
will be like
yeah fire or missile uh shoot these guys
we are
106 meters away
right and the official report will say
that even though they are probably less
um it's like uh the you know i
i shot um multiple times and the first
time i killed three the second time i
killed two
and the second everyone always brings up
the second one because the child ran
into the field of view
right well in the official report they
put that it was a dog
right um because that's
essentially what they do they overwrite
what actually happened with their
version of events
so if civilians are in the way
you know they'll call it collateral
damage and they might not even give the
correct numbers the only the only reason
that people get the correct numbers is
because we have cell phones on the
ground now and people can be like
we lost this many people and posted to
social media
um in 2014 i think there was an
app on the apple store that every time a
drone strike happened it would mark it
on a map
and it would give you local phone
numbers to call
if there were there were people in the
area um
and that was taken that was taken down
so you know as
as technology increases for the
least of us the reporting gets more
accurate
right and so these institutions can't
falsely report
things like uh yeah we killed two
high-valued individuals with
minimal collateral damage well no they
can say like there were hundreds of
people that were killed
for you to get just these two
[Laughter]
individuals